start as the game we're on we got more
comfortable with the communication
necessary to compete against philip
rivers in that environment and um and
i'm being real specific there because
competing against philip rivers is has
its challenges
but particularly in a pandemic
environment in quiet stadiums where he
gets an opportunity to communicate he
gets an opportunity to hear you
communicate
change the pace of the game and so forth
the intellectual aspect of the
schematics was really challenging
mike smith smith schuster's on record is
saying the colts were calling out your
plays in the first half and ben kind of
made it up as he went along in a second
did either of those things occur
you know uh we were calling out their
plays too um philip rivers was calling
out our adjustments i think it's one of
the things that kind of goes on in 2020
during the global pandemic when you're
playing in in crickets in in eerily
quiet stadiums um you know i know other
teams have talked about that some um i i
think it's just one of the adjustable
things that we all globally have to deal
with in the 2020 environment because of
the level of communication and the
amount of communication
that's heard between units
prior to a snap
in 2020's environment
[Music]
[Music]
kevin durafield appreciates the year-end
review of simsism great stuff from you
guys all year long it's been a whirlwind
in the leader house a different spelling
for leader house i kind of like that
spelling of your house
all right we have we have a leader house
for today's trivia question to determine
the first pick in the draft of the wild
card matchups we'd most like to see the
titans colts ravens dolphins and browns
are all ten and five and one of them
will definitely miss the playoffs
what was the last 11 and five team
because one of these teams could miss at
11 and five what was the last eleven and
five team chris to miss the playoffs
well this is like what color is blue
it's blue that's what i was saying
during the are you kidding me i mean
what the like pete what is pete like
that's the dumbest question ever of
course it's the 2008 new england
patriots
i mean
what color is red the only 11. they're
the only 11 and 5 team to miss the
playoffs now if you to ask the last 10
and 16 they'll they're not the only 11
and 5 team to miss the playoffs all
right well chris already got the
question right if the if there are more
there's not more than one more um ten
and six who's the last ten and six team
to miss the playoffs that's a good
question i'd have to look that up and i
just wrote something about it not that
long ago all right
uh chris go ahead you get the first pick
match up in the wild card round you most
want to see
well man this is a this is a tough one
because there's so many damn good
possibilities um i think the one
that i would love to see
is saints vs bucks i think that's
probably my number one choice now i
don't know exactly how that would have
to work out i think the saints would
probably have to lose this weekend
and you know seattle win to where
they're the three seed and then tampa
would have to lose and the rams would
have to win right that would make it a
3-6 matchup i tried to do this as
somewhat realistic to where it could
maybe happen even though i don't really
see that but wild card weekend
awesome here we go to start the playoffs
and if we could have one of those games
be brady versus breeze and the bucks
versus the saints and two teams that i
look at and go they could go to the
super bowl and win it uh that would be
pretty damn awesome
yeah i'm not sure that the buccaneers
could reverse the outcome from the first
two games though i'm as intrigued if not
more intrigued by another division
rivalry where there was a sweep during
the regular season where i do believe
there's a good chance that the team that
was swept could and would win round
three and that's steelers ravens that's
the one i want to see that's the one the
steelers should not want to see in the
wild card round but i think if the
steelers and ravens get together again
number one it'll be a great game and
number two i think the ravens will win
chris yeah i i i hear you there too you
know that it's a
that would be a lot of fun to watch and
it's it's rare where
you know one team loses twice and you
feel like that team that lost is is is
better in that matchup i mean it really
is rare and i will say too i think as a
professional athlete when you've lost to
a team twice
you are at a disadvantage it is a little
bit of like wait we've lost twice i
don't know if we can beat this team it's
one thing when you've lost once you can
just go back and go hey if we fix this
and this we win the game you lose twice
to a team that third time you just go
man maybe we're just not meant to beat
them are we cursed there is a
psychological element there that i find
intriguing and i'm going to go back to
my next pick is going to be one that we
talked about earlier in the show
i don't want to see it
because i don't want these two teams one
of them to be canceled out but bills
versus ravens wild card weekend would be
just unreal lamar jackson versus josh
allen that high fly and bill's offense
and stefan diggs and you know uh cole
beasley and all those guys we'll see
cole beasley's knee is all that i know
he's got the injury there but all of
them versus that ravens defense and you
know the ravens offense i think is
feeling itself right now lamar's playing
well they even found a way to infuse
wide receivers into the game just enough
to keep you off all their other stuff so
that would be a fun one for me mike
yeah i agree with you there and again
the steelers and bills should want
nothing to do with the baltimore ravens
in the playoffs i'm gonna go with
frankly what would have been my first
pick if you hadn't gotten that
incredibly difficult trivia question
correct my first pick and i i knew i
could sandbag you on this because i i
knew you weren't going to take the bucks
in two straight games and i tweeted this
yesterday the match up that most
intrigues me is buccaneers at giants
we've talked about this recently the
history between tom brady and the new
york giants a pair of super bowls that
the giants won and i know eli manning's
not walking through that door it doesn't
matter because the two teams played each
other on a monday night
such a close game a game the giants
could have should have won remember the
pass interference call in the end zone
that that really should have been called
and the giants should have had a chance
was that on the two-point try at the end
of the game that's what it was right i
think it would have been 25 25 and they
would have gone to overtime joe judge
and all the patriots coaches who are now
with the giants who know tom brady so
well
that's the one i want more than any
other i apologize i didn't make it my
first pick but i knew i could wait to
round two and still get it i probably
could have waited to round three yeah
but giants hosting the bucks is the one
i really want to see it's cool but you
could have rated it to round six and i'd
still have been there okay i mean you
know
but but yeah there is some cool story
lines there
i don't know
anything with the nfc east i'm like
i don't give a damn i don't but the last
two times we've had 500 teams host a
wild card game they've won i i know i
get that i i don't see that to be the
circumstance right now with the bucks
and the giants the way they're playing
but there is a lot of cool story lines
there i will say that i i feel
like man we're picking a lot of the same
teams over and over here um
i i wanted to go with tampa bay in
seattle
that was another one that jumped out to
me that i'd love to see i'd love to see
tom brady have to go up to play the
seattle seahawks the team that he's
beaten in the super bowl and had issues
with in the regular season and all those
things and russell wilson and seattle
and wait this defense has looked really
good the last five or six weeks in
seattle are they real can they stop a
bucks team like that you know that that
to me would be another one where i'd go
man that would be an amazing way to
start wild card weekend russell wilson
versus tom brady all of that two teams
with a little bit of attitude we know
the bucks play attitude of course the
seahawks do uh that that's probably the
the last one for me that's really
intriguing
i've got cardinal seahawks on my list
because we saw that great game earlier
this year and then the thursday night
game the rematch was pretty good when
kyle murray heard his shoulder but i'm
gonna lay off of that one since you just
went seahawks i am going to wrap this up
with the last one i thought of as i was
brainstorming the list and i thought of
it earlier this year as a potential nfc
championship rematch two years later
yeah but put the rams back in the
superdome right rams saints the return
after that ridiculous non-call of
defensive pass interference now i think
the saints would handle them easily
especially if jared goff can't play but
but just put those teams back on the
field again in a single elimination
setting i would love to see that i'm
with you there i that that would be good
a lot of fun to watch definitely it was
gonna that would be personal and there
would be cert certainly something more
than just playoffs on the line to where
you know there's a bad taste still in
the saints mouth
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports